dans ce laboratoire de la banlieue de
téhéran
des scientifiques travaillent sur la
production à grande échelle de kits de
dépistage pour le moment deux types de
kits sont fabriqués en masse il existe
des kits basé sur des analystes et sert
cette entreprise peut produire 400
milles de cqi par mois nous avons aussi
des tests sanguins que nous espérons
produire au rythme de deux millions par
semaine il s'agit de deux types de kits
différents et deux types de résultats
différents peuvent être obtenus l'un est
un test de dépistage du coup on a des
ruses et un autre sert à déterminer qui
a été infecté auparavant et quel
pourcentage de personnes sont infectées
des kits destinés principalement à la
population locale mais aussi à
l'exportation
six entreprises ont obtenu l'approbation
du ministère de la santé pour les
produire depuis ce samedi des activités
économiques à faible risque de
propagation du virus ont été autorisés à
reprendre du service dans toutes les
provinces du pays à l'exception de
téhéran la capitale
une mesure destinée à limiter les dégâts
d'une économie déjà meurtrie par le
rétablissement des sanctions américaines
l'économie ne peut pas être arrêté
les gens et le gouvernement ont besoin
de cette économie pour vivre par
conséquent l'économie doit être réactive
et progressivement
cependant il est très important que
toutes les entreprises et la population
ne gaspille pas les efforts des médecins
et obéissent aux plans de distanciation
sociale car nous pourrions alors ventre
le coronavirus et notre pays pourrait
revenir à la normale
pour autant les autorités continuent
d'appeler la population à rester à la
maison autant que possible et à veiller
au respect des règles de distanciation
sociales école université mosquées et
sanctuaires chiites cinémas lieux de
culture ou encore les stades restent
quant à eux fermés au moins jusqu'au 18
avril